all right hello everybody this is the
last week of class for at least this any
564 class and then I will have a big
nice break we'll think about everything
we've learned and we'll start again with
565 in January so this is kind of a good
place to be and I've taught you
basically everything I wanted to tell
you for the first half of the sequence
and this last week is kind of
interesting extra stuff so what I'm
going to tell you about this week
are essentially an interesting type of
solutions to a PDE called Laplace's
equation so we're already going to start
getting into partial differential
equations and we're going to talk about
very important solutions to Laplace's
equation that involve potential fluid
flows okay and what I'm hoping to do is
build the theory today and on Wednesday
and then on Friday go through a full
in-depth MATLAB example that kind of
integrates all of the things we've
talked about in the class so far so
we're going to use PDE s to define a
vector field then we're going to
integrate particles through the vector
field you know using that induced OD E
and we're going to understand when the
particles become chaotic and what that
looks like for engineering design okay
so that's what we're gonna do for the
next three lectures there's no homeworks
on this the exam won't cover this week
the exam will be cumulative up until the
last lecture and I can't remember what
it was because we've been gone for a
week speaking of which I hope everyone
had a nice Thanksgiving alright so
before I start I think that I should
give you all maybe 15 or 20 minutes
to ask any questions you want about the
final exam so the final exam will come
out on Wednesday I'll probably post it
after my office hours at 11:30 in the
morning and it'll be due on that Friday
and about 4:00 or 5:00 p.m. I haven't
quite decided maybe 4 p.m. so that we
have time to pick it up and leave
okay any any questions at all about the
final exam yeah
this Wednesday this one's a two days
from now not too fine not not the last
week of this week two days from now I'll
hand out the final online yeah my TAS
have the old homeworks so Scott Wilcox
has I think been collecting all of them
yep yeah so I wrote the final two days
ago and I don't remember putting any
Matt lot of examples on but I do have
some numerical analysis examples like
finite difference derivatives Taylor
series order of error things like that
so I have things that are related to
MATLAB but I don't think I have any
actual coding let me check I don't
remember I don't think so
let me make sure that this isn't gonna
broadcast I'm pretty sure that I don't
have any MATLAB on the final okay it
looks like it's all by hand so far yep
it's all by hand yep yeah
when was the homework I was due on
Monday last Monday then probably I'll
ask my TAS I'll see him tomorrow I think
so yeah yeah so I think it's about four
hours what I would highly recommend all
of you do is try to take it in two hours
and then use the other two hours you
know to get the rest of the so act like
it's a two-hour exam even though it's a
four-hour exam to prepare for the
qualifying exams okay so the calls are
two hours and they have more stuff on
them so I'm giving you four hours
because I don't want time to be the the
constraining you know factor for this
exam but you really should be able to
take it in two hours but I'm gonna give
you four it's a little longer and it's a
little harder but not a lot longer
or a lot harder okay but everything you
know is curved so I wouldn't worry too
much about it just do your best okay
other questions about the exam or
content driven questions okay it seems
like everyone's super confident and
ready for the final exam are we sure no
more questions okay good that's all so
we'll talk a little bit more about
actual math then so I'm super super
super excited about the next half of
this class Emmie 565 it's gonna start in
January
I'm skipping an amazing beautiful
conference in West Palm Beach just so I
can be here for the first lecture of
class and not not deliver a pre-recorded
video lecture that's how excited I am
and the entire idea for this next class
that we're going to talk about is
partial differential equations okay so
we've talked a lot about ordinary
differential equations where we have
something like this by the way is not
what I plan to tell you about today so
we've talked a lot about ordinary
differential equations like X dot equals
a times X or X dot equals f of X these
are kind of ordinary differential
equations because we have one state
variable and we're just taking a single
time derivative with respect to the
independent variable of time okay so we
have X of T where X is the dependent
variable T is the independent variable
and we're only taking derivatives with
respect to T so these are oneis
now for PDEs we're going we've already
actually seen certain types of PDEs in
the class and that's why we've been
learning about vector calculus is
because this is the language that we're
going to use to describe partial
differential equations partial
differential equations would be
something like partial X let's say I
have some function U and I'm taking the
partial derivative of U with respect to
time and let's say that that equals some
constant times the partial of U with
respect to X so now U is a function of X
and time ok so this is what I'm just
setting up the the notation here so U as
a function of X and time and the way
that what that really means is that if I
have some spatial coordinate X then you
could have some u is some function of X
and this function is changing in time ok
and what the partial differential
equation does is it constrains how this
function has to behave over time it
tells me you know something about how it
changes in time with respect to its
variation in the spatial domain for
example this you could be the
temperature on a piece of steel beam and
I might be applying some heap here and
here with a blowtorch okay that's this
is not the equation for heat on a beam
but the idea here with a partial
differential equation is now I'm taking
some function U which is a function of
multiple variables and I'm writing down
partial derivatives in a constraint
equation okay and we already just
derived a one partial differential
equation for mass continuity using
Gauss's law okay that was that density
equation we wrote down and the entire
point of the next class Emme 565 is
going to be to analyze partial
differential equations that come up all
the time and engineering so heat
equations wave equations fluid equations
elastic equations
we'll talk about Schrodinger's
Schroedinger Schrodinger's equation for
quantum mechanics optics all kinds of
neat stuff okay but it really all rests
on this idea of a partial differential
equation and we've already seen some
partial differential equations we're
going to talk about more today something
else that's important to note is that
we're going to be talking about
different coordinate systems that make
these PDE s easier to solve okay so
remember with the OD e we had X dot
equals a times X and so we would choose
a different coordinate system defined by
the eigenvectors of a so we would say
let's choose a new coordinate system
that's written in the eigen vector
coordinates of the matrix a and in this
new coordinate system we have something
much simpler which is essentially that
the dynamics are diagonal remember so a
nice change of coordinates this is a
change of coordinates so with an
appropriate change of coordinates we
took a relatively complicated coupled OD
E and we turned it into a really really
simple decoupled diagonal OD that was
very easy to solve and this is going to
be a huge theme of the next class 565
where we're going to be looking at
clever changes of coordinates that make
our partial differential equations much
much easier to solve and that's going to
be the Fourier transform and the Laplace
transform okay so Fourier and Laplace
transforms are going to be super
important for PDEs because they're going
to give us a really nice coordinate
system where the PDE is actually simple
and sometimes diagonal we're also going
to learn a lot about data science okay
so we're gonna be talking about methods
in data reduction and pattern
essentially pattern extraction from data
so that if you have an experiment that's
collecting lots and lots
data and you know that it's governed by
some underlying partial differential
equation you can use data science
methods like what Google and Facebook
and Netflix are using to extract
patterns from that data to again find a
change of coordinates into a low
dimensional basis where you can solve
this system okay so this is all stuff we
will be talking about next quarter I'm
just really excited about it and I want
to give you kind of a like a sneak peek
into what we're talking about okay so
today we're going to talk about a very
very super-important PDE called
Laplace's equation and this we're going
to introduce it in a physically
motivating way using potential flow okay
so how many of you have heard of
potential flow before okay how many of
you have had some complex variable
theory like you know complex functions
taking the derivatives of complex
functions analytic functions things like
that okay so we're gonna do this again
in the first week of the next class but
I'm going to give you a little bit of a
head start on that so last couple of
lectures we learned about Gauss's
theorem and Stokes's theorem right and
what we're going to use Stokes's theorem
and Gauss's theorem for now is to come
up with a constraint equation or a
partial differential equation that
describes a very special type of fluid
so we're going to consider a fluid that
is incompressible and irrotational
okay so incompressible
and irrotational and we're gonna call
that a fluid vector field V okay so V is
this vector field that defines you know
my fluid velocity at every point in
space so if you like V is a function of
X and T and we're going to say a few
things about this fluid flow so first of
all it's steady which means that partial
V partial T equals zero meaning it's not
really a function of time it's just a
function of space okay the partial
derivative of my vector field with
respect to time is zero it's not
changing in time okay it's also
incompressible so what did we what is
incompressible mean and vector calculus
terms Sagan yeah divergence is zero so
the div of V equals zero and let's say
that this vector field V has two
components V 1 and V 2 so it's just a
fluid velocity in 2d okay it's a 2d
fluid velocity okay so it's
incompressible and I'm not sure if I
told you it irrotational means but based
on the name irrotational no rotation
what would that be in vector calculus
terms curl is equal to zero
so curl V is also equal to zero okay so
these are the three conditions that I'm
going to impose on this this velocity
field and it seems pretty restrictive
right I'm actually putting a lot of
constraints on this this vector field V
but this type of fluid flow that's
incompressible irrotational and steady
was enough to get us about to the 1950s
in terms of airplane design okay so you
can really build a very practical
airplane using the
use constrained equations for a fluid
flow okay and we'll talk a little bit
more about that but these are actually
pretty pretty general and if you relax
this first condition one you can
actually go about two decades farther
and getting the helicopter Theory okay
so what is incompressible mean and
vector calculus that just means that
partial V one partial X plus partial so
partial V 1 partial X plus partial V 2
partial y equals zero and curl of V
equals zero means that partial V 2
partial X minus partial V 1 partial y
equals zero ok so these are the two
constraints that we have on V and what
I'm going to show you is that these are
definitely both satisfied for a special
type of vector function V here I'll show
you so if V equals the gradient of some
potential and this potential satisfies
Laplace's equation so an fie satisfies
Laplace's equation which is the second
laplacian of phi equals 0
then V satisfies conditions two and
three okay so first I need to tell you
what Laplace's equation is and why it's
important then I need to show you that
if V is defined as a gradient field
width of a potential fee that satisfies
Laplace's equation that it does in fact
have incompressibility and irrotational
properties okay so what do I mean by the
laplacian the the okay so del squared is
called the laplacian and it's kind of
like well it's exactly equal to the
divergence of the gradient of something
okay so laplacian of p is the divergence
of the gradient of fee so laplacian of
fee is the divergence of the gradient of
fee and that's equal to the divergence
of partial V partial X partial V partial
Y partial V partial Z we're just in 2d
so I'm only gonna do partial X and
partial Y and the divergence of this
vector field is okay I take the first
term and I take partial with respect to
X again so a partial squared fie partial
x squared and then I add the partial of
the second term with respect to y plus
partial squared fie partial Y squared
okay so let's think about what we're
doing here V is a scalar function V is
just a function of X scalar function
okay so fee is a scalar function
but if I take the gradient of fee then I
get a vector field right anytime I take
the gradient of a scalar function I get
a vector field because it's you know
partial V partial X partial V partial Y
it's a vector field now and if I take
the divergence of that gradient field I
get another scalar field right because
the divergence of any vector is just a
scalar and this del squared fee is given
by the sum of the partials the square
partial in X plus the second partial
derivative in Y that my function feed so
how many of you have seen this laplacian
before del squared okay I'm not gonna
harp on this and the idea is that if
this equals zero then we have this
equation equals zero this is a partial
differential equation okay
I have partial so there's some function
fee that I'm trying to solve for
possibly and I know that its second
partial derivative and X plus its second
partial derivative and Y has to equal
zero okay so this is a PDE called
Laplace's equation that's the same as
this PDE here this is just the way to
write it in terms of vector calculus so
Laplace was a big deal he did some of
the best mathematics and how many of you
have visited the Eiffel Tower so I was
pretty surprised to find what I visited
there that they actually honor their
great mathematicians by putting their
names on their monuments which is kind
of a novel idea
so Laplace's name is prominently posted
on the Eiffel Tower that's how important
Laplace is okay so what I'm going to
show you now is that if my vector field
V is defined by the gradient of a scalar
potential and that scalar potential
satisfies Laplace's equation
then we satisfy incompressibility and
irrotationality that's what i'm going to
show you now okay so okay so if V equals
V 1 V 2 and it equals grad fee then that
equals partial V partial X and partial V
partial Y alright I'm saying that my
vector field is the gradient of feet
which means that V 1 is partial V
partial X and V 2 is partial V partial Y
ok so V 1 partial V partial X V 2 is
partial V partial Y and now what we're
gonna see is that ok remember that the
divergence of V has to be 0 so
divergence of V is partial V 1 partial X
plus partial V 2 partial Y and now I'm
going to plug in this and this for V 1
and V 2 so I get partial squared V 1
partial x squared plus partial V 2
squared sorry V partial Y squared and
this is the laplacian of feet which we
said has to be 0 okay so divergence of V
is definitely equal to 0 if V is given
by the gradient of fee and fee satisfies
Laplace's equation okay so this was
conditioned to condition 3 is that the
curl of V has to equal 0 and the curl of
V is partial V 2 partial X minus partial
v one partial y okay now what was V two
partial V partial Y so I'm going to take
that partial derivative derivative with
respect to X s partial squared V partial
Y and partial X ok and minus V one is
partial V partial X and I'm taking the
partial of it with respect to Y so I get
partial squared V partial X partial Y
and these are equal and opposite and
they cancel so this also equals zero
okay so let me take a step back if I
just wanted my vector field V to be
irrotational to have curl equal zero all
I need is for V to be the gradient of
any potential fee we have this this
fundamental identity that the curl of
the gradient of fee is always equal to 0
for all V right this is one of those
vector identities that you can you can
expand this out and you can compute the
curl and you'll find that this is always
equal to 0 no matter what fee is you
don't even have to specify what fee is
this is always equal to 0 so the the
condition of V being irrotational is
easy to satisfy I just need my vector
field to be a gradient field okay
but the additional constraint of
incompressibility is not automatically
satisfied for all gradient fields it's
only satisfied for gradient fields that
satisfy this Laplace's equation ok and
this is how you could derive Laplace's
equation if you want you could say let V
be a gradient field and if I go through
all of the math and I say I want that
gradient field to have divergent zero
then I would find that my vector
potential fee has to satisfy look
flosses equation for that to be equal to
zero okay so this is a super useful
equation Laplace's equation and if fee
satisfies Laplace's equation then the
gradient field defined by fee is a
potential flow it's a flow that is
incompressible and irrotational and
steady and fortunately it's
mathematically simple enough that we can
actually do analysis on this we can
actually solve this equation on pencil
and paper or by hand which is what made
this so useful for airplanes so this is
why we could build airplanes before
computers so real fluid flows are not
incompressible or irrotational but we
make this approximation because the
flows that we're flying through at low
speeds at the early stage of airplanes
actually satisfy these approximations
and the pluses equation is much much
easier to solve than the full
navier-stokes equations for a viscous
fluid but to do real airplanes at real
you know high Mach numbers and with real
drag you would need computers to solve
those equations okay so this is an
approximation we make these constraints
on our equations we know that they're
not exactly true but they're good enough
to build real airplanes and these
constraints
give me Laplace's equation which is
probably the simplest PDE that we can
actually solve this is one of the
simplest P DS
okay so we're gonna spend a lot of time
talking about how to solve this PDE in
the next course
with lots of methods by hand and
computational but for now I'm just going
to show you some of the neat things
about this the system okay are there any
questions about what we're doing here
before I go on to some examples yeah
yeah for any fluid spoon always satisfy
the irrotationality so real fluid flows
are not given by the gradient of some
potential so so so there's kind of two
types of vector fields I let's see if I
can draw this
we don't need Laplace's equation anymore
so okay so there are let's draw like a
diagram of let's say that in the
universe there are vector fields okay so
a subset of these vector fields are and
let's call these V so some of these
vector fields are solutions to P DS okay
a smaller subset of these vector fields
are the gradient of some potential okay
and an even smaller subset of these
vector fields satisfy V equals grad fee
and the laplacian of phi equals zero so
this is kind of where we're living right
now is in this red circle a very very
restricted flows so of all possible
vector functions you can name you could
name tons of vector
functions right one vector function is
for every point in space pick a random
vector that's a vector field but it
doesn't satisfy any nice PDEs that I'm
aware of okay then there are vector
fields that are so the solution of real
PDEs like the heat equation or fluid
flow or elastic equations those are
vector fields that are the solution of P
DS a more restrictive class of vector
fields v that satisfy V equals grad fee
these are irrotational okay so
irrotational or conservative fields are
vector fields V that equal the gradient
of some scalar potential so gravitation
is an irrotational flow coulombs force
potential defines an irrotational vector
field potential flow defines a special
irrotational vector field that's also in
compressible okay so these are kind of
also get more and more difficult to
solve okay good question
other questions about what we're talking
about yeah
dissipative is happy rotational I'm
sorry like this that's a good question
no it's a good question so trying to
think of I have a simple answer
so the dissipation is often what gives
rise to like it produces rotation in the
flow I'm not sure if it's strictly
necessary yeah I can actually have a
purely non dissipative flow that does
have rotation with Euler's equations so
Euler's equation is the Navy or stokes
equation without dissipation and it
still has convection of rotation as long
as you started with some vorticity so
you can think about these things when
you're stirring up cream in your coffee
that's like a good place to start
thinking about rotational vector fields
and curl if you're really careful and
you're drinking soup or eating soup or
whatever you did a soup and you have
your spoon you can take your spoon and
you can drag it slowly through your soup
and if it's a viscous enough soup you
can get potential flow a recirculation
zone behind your spoon of counter
rotating vorticity and then if you drag
your spoon faster you'll actually get
periodic vortex shedding in the Karman
vortex streets so how does that look if
you're really stirring your soup super
fast then you'll get vortex shedding
behind your spoon and if you go much
faster than the soup will spill out I
can't get much higher than the vortex
shedding okay other questions about
potential flow or Laplace's equation or
irrotational flow
okay
so having no rotation is easy to satisfy
you just need your vector field to be
the gradient of some potential then this
will always be true in compressibility
is harder to satisfy you need that
scalar function fee to also satisfy
Laplace's equation okay that's the big
upshot here okay good so I want to tell
you a little bit more about Laplace's
equation and give you some examples of
where we use the Laplace's equation okay
so applause is equation is del squared
Phi equals 0 so this is a really really
important PDE in partial differential
equations in complex analysis so I'm
going to give you four examples of where
this comes up in physics just so you can
have in your mind like why this is
important so this comes up in
gravitation and an example is let's say
I have the earth okay and we know that
my force field is equal to minus the
gradient of some potential energy P
where P is minus mass mg over the radius
okay so we have some potential energy
for some you know point mass M out here
and it's an inverse proportion to the
radius from the center of the earth
and so you can verify by hand
that the laplacian of p equals zero so
this is actually a good exercise to do
by hand take this function if you like
you can just call this some constants
over R and you can verify that the
laplacian of this potential function the
gravitational potential is equal to zero
and that means a couple of important
things this is actually true away from
the center of the earth okay so this is
true away from masses what I'm going to
call mass sources so away from sources
of mass so in the solar system for
example you have all of these planetary
bodies and moons and as long as you're
not sitting inside of one of them this
equation is true for the gravitational
potential of all of those masses and you
can verify this by hand okay
so this means a few things this means
for example that out here you don't
actually feel any divergence right all
of the vectors are pointing basically
towards the earth so there's no
divergence away from the mass there's
also no rotation okay so that's what
this means is that the vector field has
no divergence and no rotation away from
the center and so we have lots of things
we can say about Stokes's theorem and
Gauss's theorem so what are some things
we could say like if I was on a roller
coaster
with no friction in a gravitational
field conservation of energy would hold
okay so for curl free vector fields we
have conservation of energy okay another
example is electrostatics
it's basically the same as gravitation
this is away from point charges so this
is super similar to gravitation except
your forces are opposite so if I have a
couple of point charges then they define
a vector field and as long as I'm not
sitting directly on one of those
singular point sources then Laplace's
equation is going to hold okay so notice
that the only points that actually have
positive divergence are at these sources
of mass and charge okay so I can have
points that have positive divergence but
everywhere else in this field
I have no divergence and no rotation
okay maybe the more interesting examples
are heat transfer so let's talk about
how many of you are taking a heat
transfer class right now maybe there's
not an offered okay so the heat transfer
is probably the easiest one to think
about because this one's actually
intuitive we can reason through what the
solution is without any math just from
physical intuition so let's think about
heat conduction and in particular we're
going to talk about steady state heat
conduction
so we're gonna have a variable T which
is temperature and one of the things
were that we're going to derive in the
next half of this class is the heat
equation so the change in temperature
with respect to time is given by some
constant squared times the laplacian of
the temperature this is the heat
equation and we're going to derive this
using vector calculus identities in the
next class but first steady state that
means that this temperature distribution
is stationary and is not changing in
time so steady state means that this
partial partial T is 0 so it just means
that the laplacian of my temperature is
equal to 0 okay and the way I like to
think about that is the following let's
say that I have some steel plate and
it's not radiating or doing anything
funny it's like you know insulated and I
start out by applying a blowtorch to the
center of this thing ok so I have a
blowtorch that's giving me a very very
hot distribution at the center of the
blowtorch and then I take the blowtorch
away what's going to happen as time goes
to infinity as the system reaches steady
state it's eventually all going to
become the same temperature right so
this heat is going to diffuse and spread
throughout the entire plate until
eventually this whole thing is going to
be one constant temperature ok and so
what that means is that as time goes to
infinity or as this system reaches
steady state one solution of Laplace's
equation is temperature equals a
constant
does that make that actually makes sense
right because if I take temperature
equals a constant
and I take the partials with respect to
X and I add them to the partials with
respect to Y then they do actually
satisfy Laplace's equation so this
satisfies Laplace's equation ok so a
constant temperature distribution is
kind of a very simple or trivial
solution of Laplace's equation
I could have other solutions where I
actually impose a temperature on the
boundaries and then you get some kind of
linear gradients temperature
distribution on this plate that would
also satisfy Laplace's equation and
we're gonna go way more into detail with
this later okay and then the fourth the
fourth physical equation that satisfies
Laplace's equation is the potential flow
we were talking about and potential flow
is going to be really really useful for
thinking about things like if I have
fluid flow past an airfoil how does that
fluid move over that airfoil or over
that surface so if I was going to
streamline a wing or a ship or wind
turbine blade then I could use potential
flow to figure out how there is going to
move over the surface okay so if you've
ever heard of streamlines for a fluid
flow streamlines are very intimately
related to potential flow solutions okay
ok any questions about Laplace's
equation or these kind of four canonical
examples
okay so in the next lecture I'm going to
give you examples of potential flow like
we're actually going to compute what a
flow would do past an airfoil or past a
cylinder or past a square object and
then in the third lecture I'm going to
show you an example of a really really
useful potential flow that's actually
used to model ocean ocean currents so
it's called the double gyre and a gyre
just means a big rotating region so the
idea is that I have this big kind of
Ocean gyre that's sloshing back and
forth okay so this could model for
example the Pacific Ocean or the
coupling between the Gulf of Mexico and
South Atlantic and this double gyre flow
can be kind of approximated with
potential flow and it's going to allow
us to study things like mixing in oceans
okay so if you want to know how plant
life or oxygen or temperature get mixed
by ocean currents this is a simple toy
model built on potential flow that we
can use to test our theories so that's
where we're going
we're going to kind of zoom in on
potential flow we're gonna look at some
you know particularly useful examples of
potential flows show that they satisfy
Laplace's equation and then we're going
to build this mathematical model in that
lab for ocean ocean sloshing okay that's
it for today on Wednesday you will get a
the last midterm or the final exam for
the class
you